يعد استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
اتجاهًا متزايدًا وهو أن
الجيش يعتمد تحديد
الأهداف في غزة وأعتقد أن العام الجيد
للنظر إليه لفهم
بدايته فيما يتعلق بغزة هو عام
2019 عندما يكون الرئيس  من الموظفين aiv kavi
uh قدم هذا القسم الجديد في
الجيش الذي يسمى قسم الأهداف وكانت
فكرته هي جمع مئات
الجنود معًا والبدء بشكل أساسي في
تطوير هذه الخوارزميات
والبرامج الآلية لتسريع
عملية إنشاء الأهداف للضربات التي تؤدي إلى
عواقب الحياة والموت في  غزة، وكما
تعلمون، قال مصدر شارك بالفعل في
مركز الشعبة هذا إنه
لم يتم الحكم عليهم من خلال جودة
الأهداف التي كانوا ينتجونها ولكن من خلال
الكمية التي أصبحت الآن جميع
القيود السابقة التي كانت
تسمح بالفعل بإيذاء المدنيين
تم تخفيفها بشكل كبير على سبيل المثال،
تحدث أحد المصادر عن كيفية الحصول على نوع
من هذا التقريب لمكان الهدف وهو
غير محدد ومع ذلك
سيستمر الجنود في ضربه عن عمد مما يؤدي إلى
مقتل العائلات والمدنيين لتوفير
الوقت لتوفير الوقت في الحصول على
تحديد أكثر دقة  الهدف
هناك سياسة منهجية وفقا
لمصادر استهداف المنازل السكنية الخاصة
لنشطاء حماس أو الجهاديين عندما
يكونون في هذه المنازل الخاصة عندما
يكونون في هذه المباني أو
المساكن الخاصة وفقط حتى
تفهم ما يعنيه هذا  هو أن
الجيش يسقط عمدا
قنبلة تزن طنًا أو في كثير من الأحيان
أكثر على مبنى سكني من أجل
اغتيال شخص واحد، مما يؤدي إلى
قتل عائلة ذلك الشخص
وجيرانه عمدًا في هذه العملية عندما تكون هذه المباني، وفقًا
للمصادر، في الغالبية العظمى من الحالات
ليس الأماكن التي
يتم فيها نشاط عسكري
هو اغتيال
لشخص في حماس أو
ألوية الجهاد العسكرية أه لكنهم ليسوا في
مكان عسكري كان أحد المصادر
ينتقد بشكل خاص هذه السياسة
قال إنه يعتقد أنها مثل  إذا قامت
مجموعة فلسطينية مسلحة بقصف
منازل الإسرائيليين ليس عندما
يرتدون زيهم العسكري ولكن عندما
يعودون إلى منازلهم في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع،
واغتيالهم بشكل أساسي
من خلال جثث
عائلاتهم أو جيرانهم ثم
قول ذلك  يستخدمون تلك العائلات
كدروع بشرية